[Music]
i also wanted to
uh welcome you to twitter you just you
just joined twitter yeah i just joined
twitter yeah how's it going well it's
pretty fun but i wanna i was wondering
if i could you know do a tweet with you
sure yeah yeah i mean uh like a what
like say something or like a photo let's
let's do a photo okay okay all right
right now that you can tweet out yeah
what can we do because i want to be
tweeted on your twitter
i get that all the time
that means nothing uh i don't know what
do you want to do something uh different
yoga poses yoga pose would be great yeah
can you show us a cool yoga pose can you
do that in that dress are you okay all
right okay why don't you show us a yoga
pose and we'll figure out something to
do andy can you take a i i was told to
have a camera ready okay oh my god okay
okay
[Applause]
that was fantastic heather graham ladies
and gentlemen hangover part three
we're right back comedian jen kirkman's
here stick around
[Applause]